how do you always buy clothes that you
don't buy the full version of it you
know they have holes in it hey did you
like ripped off literally is it like an
assassin's Creed character hi are you
cute what happened to this exactly what
I said
she got ripped off they she and sweater
yeah so we are here about the grub at
SlapFish now I've been following
SlapFish on Instagram for the longest
[ __ ] time and they're very far from
where I'm at so I have to drive a
distance to make sure that can come here
and eat the food literally every night
before I've been going to sleep I've
been watching the food on Instagram yeah
so they have they're known for their
seafood slap fish and um they have
something called their clop stirol' so
it's like like crab and lobster
um um and they have a mac and cheese or
they have a grilled cheese with crab and
lobster sided as well the clam chowder
supposed to be pretty [ __ ] amazing I
know
sorry go come on now sourdough bread I
believe so
that was David I'm straight Dave that
wasn't me no sweater no I don't know
what work that your body we're sewing
honey
finish it go return to your sweater huh
aren't you cold I took coal she tries
the cloud on somebody you can't cloud
anybody with that sweater that's the
problem one of the reasons I was super
excited to try this place is not only
because the food looks good it's just
that you're getting Lobster and you're
getting all this other stuff that
normally when you go to other places
like it's ridiculously expensive so I'm
not sure how great it's going to taste
because the price kind of scares me but
we just ordered probably food for about
like six or seven people and it costs
about a hundred dollars which isn't bad
for fresh seafood yeah that's really
good
so hopefully it matches up to my
expectations there's a part of Instagram
where they take the cheese and they go
like that do it
so here we go we have these lobster
taquitos that are the special today
she suggested it my new friend over
there and we have these house-made
pickles [ __ ] with some pickle [ __ ]
with some pickled onions on top of that
and then we have our sauce on the side
and of course we have our very delicious
clam chowder the you about know
protecting right now right Bunyan and
then right here inside she's a San
Franciscan too by the way so she knows
not clam chowder backing me up
soory mean that's pretty clammy goodness
yes I actually like my clam chowder a
little more thick I think New England
clam chowder is a little bit more runny
which is perfectly fine I like it thick
like this I want it to be the
consistency of green people love pickles
I don't really have our shoes let me do
it for you now like this is you know
she's such as she's such a mother should
we choose it Jim
whoa no one expected it's like
refreshing is very good this is the
I'm 11 actually like those two though
like the perfect amount of Chris it's
like punching but it's still soft and
doing take a team in which toggles are
one of my favorite things to eat on this
earth general anything rather than a
taco but I gotta tell you this is a
pretty [ __ ] fish taco and now Ellen
I'm gonna dig into this - fried of
course because yeah I got titties
Oh spider how you like your eggs
Frodo nine
one of the best responses I've ever had
by like a super light is not very heavy
the cream sauce isn't overpowering super
crispy fish taco and they actually have
I'm asking with the twin of the ship
because I think it's crack so ask
Lobster creamy caramelized onions and a
nice burger patty is there
surf and turf burger look at this look
at this [ __ ] yeah
I know
what's so great you can actually taste
the lobster it's not fake shitty-ass
lobster either you actually get in good
final ops and you see that [ __ ] it's
like a Big Mac right yeah a little bit a
lobster Big Mac mm-hmm
so this right here is a fable flopster
grilled cheese sandwiches half a crab
have lobster and most people say that
you can't add cheese to Cebu well what
do we say to that Melanie but [ __ ] you
LPS good
ow
this is know what I love you know what
we say if your rap battle in the food
that means is good this [ __ ] right here
this [ __ ] yo listen
yo I'm tired this sandwich you know it's
all up in my tummy
this [ __ ] is stupid this oh man I'm
feeling real dummy
oh crap y'all lay on my level I'm about
to devour this [ __ ] he's about to go in
my mouth digest and they come out their
[ __ ] so damn good you guys have to try
this oh my god it's so good and the
cheese is an overpowering even you can
still taste the secret and that's what I
like lobster roll
our meeting
I don't know we'll be able to chop this
I think I just had to feed you Oh get
ready ah okay come on I want like a
monster but Dinah oh that's my finger
what do you think this is any better
because you can't go after that that's
hard to do a follow-up yeah but this
delicious I'm not the wrong with that
bowl you know I'm eating these french
fries don't even ask me why when I come
through here I tried everything that's
why they call me the tribe guy you can't
stop me you can't even see me when I eat
this fruit because it's invisible in me
Oh what do it
it takes it takes a couple of years it
takes a couple of years watch this it's
not going to go into gonna come yeah try
it so today I woke up and I went to me
to go to t-mobile and they told me that
if I sign up for the programs that I
could have my face time and then a meal
plans I was like I'll cavity oh my god
were you eat 40 no I can be
self-deprecating
can you sing one of his songs right now
let sprinkle me 40 water Oh easy that's
easy
oh Jesus Christ head read so shaken I
got dressed of living on Bravo sir
imagine all the rooms go and done
shipping i whatever get the full enough
hi whoo tell me when the girl just
talking on my get you on my white girl
out tell me when it yup tell me when the
girl
duh-duh-duh-duh oh my gosh I used to be
all of them probably all about my wife I
do like this I put a look on my face
like I smell some piss bounce to the
beat - let's start dinner then I'll just
stop that smirk off my shirt what is
that I smack break
Oh Jamie Mac David and I'm saying it but
me and Mac Deezy
Oh
I [ __ ] your [ __ ] up my dad no good okay
you harmonize it's great how do you feel
I am gonna go sleep I'm so full it's
very yeah yeah how do you feel like I
need to ma'am ma'am
slab fish did not disappoint however I
do wish the lobster roll had more
Lobster in it a little too much the
bread to Lobster ratio wasn't that great
but that [ __ ] crops are grilled
cheese you help me it's so good but I'm
lactose so it's like wow thank you for
letting us just our car ride home then
even a network or board worth living in
there's work work work was payment
independent now we're gonna get to my
sorry both from the safe code so this
under something I don't know so we
cancel foo-foo-foo-foo CQ
boop-boo-boo-boop
your child's going to be really weird
you know wrapping it so easy you just
talk [ __ ] and sometimes you could just
use the same word over and over like I
was doing in there watch listen I am the
[ __ ] man step up to me homie you ain't
even [ __ ] man I swear to god homie I
will take you down because I am the [ __ ]
man you ain't [ __ ] methanol [ __ ] this
[ __ ] you out [ __ ] oh ok ok like oh my
name is Ellen Kim like [ __ ] you man like
I say [ __ ] you man I see the sky and say
[ __ ] yo man see dude that's good listen
listen I'm from a place where you should
know the three digits I'm talking about
the nine one six when we get while we
get down we end up the up and out Clips
I put a couple bullets through your
chest homie you might end up dead you
ain't gonna find me homie you could even
ask the vents I've been chased around
cousins I've been [ __ ] around with you
ain't nut to me man I put a chain on
your [ __ ] neck and next thing you
know you my [ __ ] game over
I told y'all to stop this ain't nothin I
can take you down [ __ ] I pulled
that muffin back top black you did son
uh-huh it's always he is the same one I
don't know that was too good my name is
Ali Kim I'm from the four one five hell
yeah I like that
you're good I was walking down the
street and I was like cellphone what
birds in the fly psychic aha Oh pheeb up
[ __ ] that's tight that's Boris really
when the rains coming down homie I'll be
safe I'll be turning on my [ __ ] wipers
I got a daughter she 2 years old I'm
that dude that stay at home and I change
the diapers that's right
I'll bring my kid hood alphabets because
I want her to be smart
see [ __ ] out the other ship when you
hear people saying in about the RC I
love the arch that's when my kids going
to be dancing I want to be chilling with
the friends every day I want her to be
laughing [ __ ] doing what I did I used to
be a thug now all I do is with my arms
open wide I show people my love see I
freestyle all day been doing it since I
was a baby all day got bit by I can't
never got rain hell yeah bars boys